I want to start by discussing the
subject of play people often view
sciences a very serious exploit but it's
really quite playful and you in
particular keep play at the forefront of
your research activities can you tell me
how play figures in your research I came
to do my PhD in with Andre in 1999 and
at first for me it was just an
opportunity to work in in some other lab
but I was so fascinated with the style
of work which I'm really imposed on the
lab that I worked with him in the cell
in the same lab since then and it's
really important that you an Android
imposed the style which promotes the the
freedom of mind he just allowed to do
whatever you want as long as it is not
boring and for me I'm not sure if
weather even if we're not doing science
in the eyes of other people it's it's
nice it's it's enjoyable and that's what
was alive I suppose when children start
off being curious about the world and
they do their first experiments that's
just play they're just playing around
but somehow most people lose that
ability to fulfill their curiosity
through play I think saying that it's
apply it's a little bit of exaggeration
but I will put it a slightly different
manner of speech so essentially science
is not a hundred meter race okay you
have to do marathon for 4050 years of
your life and to keep you active and
keep your I mean you have to keep some
interest in your research if you are
doing something like your PhD supervisor
gave your project and them from
scientific cradle to scientific often
you go just along the straight railway
line that's boring
so it doesn't keep you involved doesn't
keep you interested so during this work
you try to make it more fun more
interest try to new direction step left
step right no problem at all
you